[Music]
this video will of course contain
spoilers for the book god emperor of
dune
of the many great and powerful dukes
barons and emperors of the dune universe
none have had more impact than the god
emperor lato the second
his eventual powers would dwarf those of
even his father
paul atreides his influence outgrew the
guild
all of chome even the bini jesuit
the great houses of the landsrad were
rendered irrelevant
he controlled the flow of spice
throughout the universe
and no one moved throughout his empire
without his knowledge
his prescient eye reached to the
furthest reaches of time
almost nothing was hidden from him he
was the most powerful human being who
ever lived by far
and the most oppressive imperial
dictator of all time
never before had the whole of humanity
been held in such a tight grip
but even he was vulnerable the god
emperor possessed secrets
these hidden vulnerabilities are
ultimately the key to his
undoing the first of the god emperor's
secrets
which duncan idaho was supposedly put in
charge of maintaining
was simply the fact that he was
vulnerable
he was not truly a god as many
throughout the human universe truly
believed
he could be harmed he could be killed
you will be asked to guard me by
whatever means necessary
and you will be asked to guard my secret
what secret
that i am vulnerable that you are not
god
not in that ultimate sense
lato's origins had been purposely
obscured
only the most perceptive entities in the
universe like the bini jesuit
and the chile laksu understood that he
was the descendant of paul atreides
the average human in nato's empire was
less aware of the emperor's nature
lato understood that it was easier to
main control over the people of the
empire
if enough of them believed that he was
truly a god
in the absolute sense immortal and
unkillable
but in truth lato would always be human
a vast multitude of human lives lived
within him
though he lived within a pre-worm body
and though his brain was no longer a
brain of human dimensions
his mind held the true essence of
humanity
and this leads to lato's next secret
which he actually considered his
ultimate secret
later was human in the most essential
sense
he had the ability to love siona
atreides first realizes this fact
when later ii allows her to escape with
some of his journals
which she and other rebels had stolen
from his palace
she finds a passage which mentions the
death of the god emperor's sister
gennima it is there that she comes to
the realization
he loved his sister yes
he is capable of love oh yes we have him
now
as eons passed him by he had loved many
companions
all of which he watched die he had been
filled with sorrow each time
he knew that if his enemies uncovered
this fact about him
that they could use this vulnerability
to manipulate him
the ixians had also uncovered his secret
specifically one man which the god
emperor had seemed to favor
named malki malki eventually acquired an
even greater understanding of the god
emperor
than his closest servant maneo he
recognized the emperor's vulnerability
using ixian technology a no room
a chamber which could hide those within
from prescient vision
he created we nori
my most secret secret is exposed
they had discovered his secret we was
the evidence of it
we nori had been genetically engineered
and conditioned for one purpose alone
to make the god emperor love her she had
been created from malki's own cells
just a few tiny cells from my body marky
said
then carefully nurtured growth and
education
everything and exact opposite to your
old friend malki
we did it all in the no room where you
cannot see
somehow the ixians had intended to use
we
to destroy laeto but they had not
intended on we
nor re to return lato's love
regardless before the ixians could act
upon their plans
siona atreides got to the god emperor
first
lato's final secret was the manner in
which he was vulnerable
he was immune to most conventional
weapons
but just as the great worms of ancient
arrakis had been
lato was too averse to water
moisture was poisoned to him
this is the secret that siona atreides
uses at the end of the book god
emperor of dune to end lato
she discovered the fact after lato
brought her into his desert to be tested
later had a small desert which was
maintained on rakis by weather machines
the planet during the time of the god
emperor had been terraformed
the process had eliminated the deep
desert entirely
laetos desert was the only desert on the
planet
a place where he could roam freely by
chance his weather machines
malfunctioned
it rained briefly and sionna saw the
effect it had on him
the clouds passed and it was a few
moments before siona sensed his
disturbance
what's wrong with you he was unable to
answer
the rain was gone but the water remained
on the rocks
and in puddles all around and beneath
him there was no escape
siana saw the blue smoke rising from
every place the water touched him
it's the water when lato is drenched
momentarily in the rain water
the sand trout cilia which make up his
skin start to begin the process of
separation
his body begins to produce true spice
essence
which siona can see as puffs of blue
smoke
she realizes in that moment that enough
water
could probably kill him he was not human
not like her at all and she possessed
the secret of his undoing
ring him with water destroy his desert
immobilize him with a moat of agony
siona uses this knowledge of lato's
weakness
to assassinate him at the end of the
book the god emperor had managed to
maintain rule of the human empire
and safeguard his secrets for nearly
four thousand years before he was undone
by his own creation siona
it can be argued that leitel allowed
himself to be killed
as a necessary part of his golden path
hi guys quinn here thank you for
watching my video
make sure you like and subscribe if you
enjoy the content
and also if you want to support this
channel consider clicking the
patreon link and pledging a dollar or
two per month
you can also make a one-time donation by
clicking the paypal link
in the description and while you're here
you can totally go follow me on twitter
which is totally free and it also helps
me spread my reach as a content creator
thank you guys so much again peace out